Can we begin
Good morning how are you
So as I believe You know from the
media from the media code of this of
this
event president ursolfonder Lion has one
also one
at least one more appointment So
let's say so let's
help this one with this meeting to
go away as easily as possible
and as quickly as possible
We are here now
now to present this book We will
talk about it extensively So I skip
my presentation directly because
I think it is the least interesting of
all and in the meantime I would like to call here two
people who have contributed a lot to
this project in the meantime Carlo
Feltrinelli  that as usual
Carlo puts his face on books
[Applause] it
works Good morning well found Thanks
for being here I will steal you for a few moments
I would simply like to
thank and warmly greet
Davide Sassoli's family in
particular
in particular Sandra who made
this book possible  we're going
to present  re that will be in all
Italian bookstores I also want to say
that the proceeds from this book will be
donated to the
oncological entity of Aviano
I want and then let's say the
exceptional presence of the president Ursula Fano
who is required to be with us in
attendance despite an agenda that
I imagine particularly
complicated and then all the authorities
present starting from the minister Antonio
Tajani and Raffaele Fitto and the mayor of
Rome who to whom Roberto Gualtieri will
find the word shortly and what to say
in short In two days it will be the first
anniversary of David's disappearance
Sassoli and let's say that for us like
Feltrinelli there couldn't be a free person
symbolically more important to
inaugurate this new year of activity
This book is a collection of
interventions in the European field by Sassoli
It is a way to continue to be in his
company as the president wrote
Sergio Mattarella in his introduction
we thank him enormously for this
contribution
Um, as we know there are different ideas
of Europe that of David Sassoli was
a very precise idea because it had in the
foreground the centrality of people
the protection of rights respect for
difference and priorities and an idea
supported every step by the pride of the
European Democratic model we know
of his commitment in recent years of his
passion of his leading role
also in the turning point that led
the union to
policies during the pandemic that
provided for
unprecedented internal solidarity tools
this spirit is today it is today it is in
place  test today from what we know
in the days of the war in Ukraine In the
confrontation with autocratic and authoritarian systems,
even with the unfortunate theme,
let's say about the
internal scanders that we have learned about in
recent weeks and no one can say
once and for all whether we will be up to
the challenges that  they await us because
democracy rights must be cared for and
maintained on a daily basis for this
we believe that  this book is
particularly important is a
training ground for Europeanism
where by remaining in the company of David
Sassoli hopefully
young readers will be able to rediscover the
deep meaning of European roots and also
that planning hope for
a more united Europe more modern more
authoritative wisdom and audacity  the title of the
book recalls and taken from the
words davisan history delivers in his
teaching speech when he said
that in times
of great transformations
new ideas are needed to govern. It takes courage.
wisdom and in some way the wish
that we feel like giving to the Europe to
come Many thanks
Thank you
Carlo Feltrinelli I
think that
our guest, the man who is
hosting us technically here in Rome, would also like to say hello the
mayor of Rome  Gualtieri mayor
[Applause]
the president of the commissio  ne
European
authorities present Dear Sandra Livia
Giulio I really want to extend the
warmest greetings of welcome to all of you
and really thank
Feltrinelli publisher Claudio Sardinian Sandra
and everyone who worked on this
beautiful, very beautiful volume
that allows us to remember David
almost a year  since his
death
fully appreciating the scope of his
truly extraordinary contribution
political ideal to the cause the values ​​in which he
believed
Europe to good politics
that his experience as President of
Parliament
David has been able to put all
his passion and dedication into the matter
for European ideals he publishes all the
virtues that came to him from his
political culture as a Catholic Democrat of
Dossettian inspiration la Piana
all his meekness and at the same time those who
knew him his
determination his idea of ​​politics as a process
as convergence and at the same time
his audacity his openness writes
Cla  Sardinian audio in his Introduction
to the prophecy let's say his
strong defense of the community method of the role
of the European Parliament at the same time
his never
procedural vision of these passages but
rooted in the centrality of the person
in an idea of ​​politics which must be
representation and also  capacity for
eschatological vision of the depths he once said,
quoting a complex thought by di la
pila on the ability to grasp even the
movements that emerge on the surface
only
after his
election
I remember well those days as President
of the parliament it took place at a time
when Europe  its own institutional structure was challenged in a
profound way in its values ​​and
principles
by an approach that
had forcefully manifested itself in those
lessons and which then shortly thereafter
would also be seen in an
Italian political crisis
of sovereign nationalist inspiration
at the  which it was necessary to be able to respond
not only with the of  front but also with the
push for change in Europe and
his election marked the first
step in defining not only
a political perimeter of a
majority but also an agenda for
change and renewal of Europe
capable of  face the challenges that
were in front of us at that time
migration climate and then those that
proved capable of facing the new ones
starting from Copit to
mend a rift between Europe and the
people that
too narrow a development of the
integration process had helped to make
emerge and that agenda was seen in
the ambitious program with which
Ursula van der Lyon DL was elected and then in the
ability to respond
to the pandemic with new tools and Davide owes a very
important contribution to this
in the third part of the volume there are the
interventions that traditionally the
President of the European Parliament
pronounces before the
European Council takes place
we don't always say so To those who repeat
years of those interventions are dealing with
documents that are inside the real themes in
question and the discussion or that
prefigure the solutions that
would then be taken Here is David, it is
impressive to re-read the one of 26
March 20 in which
new tools were asked and starting from a
common debt mechanism
that of April 23, 2020
extraordinary plan interventions David was
among those Among the main ones
who successfully However, if you imagine and
think about what then the union Thanks
to the contribution of all the commission of
many member states and you manage to do
saving Europe and opening a
new season which naturally today is measured
against
equally complex, difficult and
tragic challenges starting with the war but which
have shown a strength and capacity
of the European project to give answers
that others have not been able to give and to whom
today
might consider
defeats and archived that season
that led
to David's election to that age  nda
Perhaps it should be noted that the
character of historical development
is never that of a pendulum in which one
moves statically from one side
to the other but a dialectical process in
which each phase contributes to transforming
the following one and if today
the terms of the  political debate
on Europe in Italy in Europe are
so different from those of 2019
this is thanks to all those who are
helping to make today's debate better
but also because the seeds of the challenge that
saw David as protagonist have
borne fruit and L  Europe has managed to
mend that rift with the people who
at that stage was dangerously
widening today of course faced with
such difficult and demanding problems
we particularly
miss David of his intelligence of
his ability of his meekness of his
courage David really  is missing and
will be terribly missed
at the same time I think this volume
helps us understand that  his
sermons were not useless But that his
extraordinary commitment has made a
truly extraordinary contribution to
changing Italy and Europe in depth and for the better
and today we have
the duty to continue and to be
consistent with those ideals with that
courage  with that strong vision of
wider unity around the values ​​and
principles of the European project
a minister is prepared to say goodbye if he feels like it
Good morning everyone Thanks also for the
unexpected
I was
President of Parliament with David
Sassoli my vice president
I was then president of
the constitutional affairs commission with
David President of Parliament
or militating on different fronts for politicians
let's say almost opposites but
we have always
defended
the ist together  he democratic institution of the European
Union we have defended, trying to
enhance it in the best possible way
, the European Parliament which has
to deal with the commission which has
to deal with the council and we have
always fought so that there was a power
of legislative initiative for the
European Parliament in order
to  undertake
a process of greater democratization
of the European Union to bring it ever
closer to the citizens
defending the institutions
is neither being of the center nor of the
right and left the institutions
must always and in any case be respected and
defended and this can be done by being
representatives of  a party or
representatives of another
political party The important thing is to defend a
democratic regime The important thing is to
defend it we did two
Italian parliamentary presidents
who succeeded one another after so many years of
absence I was the first Italian
to preside over Parliament
electrodemocratically David was
the second before  we had
never been there and we have always sought
both and from me as I have
always had all possible support from
him and so he has from me
we have always
confronted each other we have always had a
common vision of the institution Here we have
done  so that this Parliament
could
be an institution on which
the spotlight was turned on in Italy and in
Europe we tried
to honor our country at the same time because we were
elected in Italy we represented
Italian citizens in Europe but we had
the honor and the burden of  lead a
community institution So we have
always protected together the interest
of the European Union of the
values ​​in which we believed I
conclude by recalling an episode which
was when we went to welcome
both of us we were vice presidents because
before my election we were
both vice presidents of the
European Parliament going to  welcome Pope
Francis and what a memory
that  brings together two people who, I repeat, although they
militate in different political forces,
were both believers and
we went to welcome them and we told them
Pope Francis not only as vice
president of the European Parliament but
as believers Here I think
this fact also united
and always made us feel
close to that I remember David so
I remember and conclude seriously
the day before his candidacy
within the socialist group he
called me was we lean
on one of the balconies overlooking
what the ideal river inside
the European parliament says that  I think
what I have to do if there is the possibility,
run, go and do we continue to have an Italian
President of the European Parliament
In short, we spoke for almost an hour
together Then later he ran as a candidate and became
President of the Parliament and This
allowed Italy once again to
be a protagonist of the European institutions I
am delighted that a volume is being published today
that ra  he welcomes his
speeches and I think it is important to
remember a character like David
because he gave his soul
for the community institutions which
owe him a debt of gratitude I am grateful to him and I
also thank his family
always for wanting to politely
reserve the memory of  a
good President of the European Parliament
Thank you minister Thank you very much
So I have to give the floor of course
to the president
whom I thank for coming As
mayor Gualtieri has already underlined but
I would like to underline it here I
use the fonderling the majority
that the nominee you read owed something
serious to an idea of ​​Sassoli this
I think is important because celebrating
people is not a fact of friendship
celebrating people a fact of
recognizing them above all the role they
have played in our lives David
Sassoli had an intuition in having
just arrived more or less  less in supporting
this project this project
for Italy his election presid  institution
was also a time of change
because if you remember I don't have to
tell you Europe were a
very turbulent situation your election
also had an impact on
Italian national politics which was felt
really much later In
short, Europe though  remains turbulent even
now almost four years after your
election I would like you to remember
Davide but also if it is
possible to give us an idea of ​​how we continue along
those lines How to say that you
also indicate our foreign minister
with a community that is  able to
maintain what we celebrate here today
as Davide but in reality it is the
community of the community in recent years
that is a community that is not an enemy a
real community that takes
all the problems on its own shoulders and those
of the covip now I don't know how it will continue
with the war Here if you tell us a
little about your idea so we can also give you
some news, in short, your idea on
how to continue from here  i to the challenge of
2024 which is no simpler than
that of the 19th Thank
you from Antonio minister rented by Raffaele
meio Gualtieri from
roberto's
via Romano
distinguish I
mrs Sassoli dearest Alessandra
[Applause]
dear Livia and Giulio
Thank you very much
Thank you very much for  me to Join Today
and many many Saints to davits Friends
and colies together
[Music]
David
Special connection to Netflix
side out Place Into the shelter For
War Office
David Maria Turoldo
David Maria Sassoli Wesley
on the day of
the Camp
Survivors
and the Children of the  victims
played the silence
[Applause]
[Music]
that Times
and David
in the final section of this book
in the Holy man's for maddals David
[Music]
speaker
S of Find politici
of palestics
and the logics of Power
[Applause]
David
the good president
[Applause]
[Music]